antoine bonjour dernière journée doit
être ce mercredi donc et sans doute la
plus importante
oui tout à fait c'est le 1er juillet
jour ultime de ce vote et jour lors
duquel les autorités électorales
s'attendent à accueillir le plus de
monde ouvert depuis une semaine ses
bureaux de vote ont déjà accueilli une
partie importante du corps électoral
après cinq jours la participation
s'élevait à 45 7% et là les chiffres à
midi viennent de tomber des chiffres
issus de la commission électorale
centrale la participation s'élève à
57,43 % alors noter que lors de cette
dernière journée le vote électronique
n'est plus disponible il l'était pour
les habitants de la région de moscou et
ceux de la région de nijni novgorod
jusqu'à hier soir alors on le sait ces
amendements à la constitution ont déjà
été adoptées par le législateur par le
parlement russe mais voilà avec ce
scrutin de la demi-heure poutine cherche
à donner une assise cherche à donner une
certaine légitimité populaire à cette
réforme le président russe ainsi que le
premier ministre qui se sont d'ores et
déjà déplacés dans leurs bulles dans
leurs bureaux de vote pour y déposer
leur bulletin dans l'urne
merci beaucoup en talk l'hérault